we going yeah what's going on baby birds
Nick here just hanging out I want to let
you guys know we're definitely be coming
out with some patreon content soon we've
been slacking a little but we got some
fun stuff coming I don't want to promise
anything cuz we haven't done any of it
yet but it's gonna be some extra content
and you know just the same old [ __ ]
you've come to expect and love from us
yeah like oh here's one thing I can't
promise a best-of clip show just like we
did for Nick vile season of rachel
season that that's in the camp we just
got to post that so look out for that
sorry I would leave the patron ID quit
right now if I were you guys I don't
know alright well hey next hater
do you have anything else to say uh nope
I could just that I could easily do this
for 15 minutes okay well you're at a
minute right now so how do you feel fine
okay you know what let's just turn this
into a 15 minute video is there any
danger in staying here cuz that's the
only thing I'm worried well when I do it
my eyes feel like they're gonna fall out
of my head and I think that that is dude
your face is so [ __ ] ugly upside down
it is making me very smooth and looks
like something from like labyrinth like
some scary yeah it looks just so much
creature design it just looks really
scary so it wasn't 15 minutes while
being berated alright so a minute you're
it two minutes right now and if
the audience if you didn't want to keep
watching that's completely
understandable but I think that we
should take this time to learn a lot
about Nick right now so Nick give me
your top three favorite movies Dark
Knight Dumb and Dumber and Space Jam
okay so I don't understand the space Jim
I agree with the other childhood
nostalgia generation honestly pretty
funny writing Bill Murray has some
hilarious parts and it doesn't hold up I
disagree I disagree I watched on vh1
just recently okay how big is your penis
bigger than average I like I see like
six and a half don't you don't need to
humble off Nick I was with a lady who
has seen a lot of penises and she said
he was very quiet are Mary Carey yeah I
know funny thing about next past sexual
history he's had sex with Mary Kerry who
is a yeah she's a good person she's a
really nice person damage sandwich so
but she's she finished top ten in the
gubernatorial race in California yeah so
you have that feather to put in your cap
but you know she has confessed to having
up to three penises in her [ __ ] at
one time well did you know that uh
doesn't surprise me
she still called me big dick Nick that's
so cool god your face is so [ __ ]
horrific upside down it looks like it it
looks like a [ __ ] can't say that word
it looks like Gollum you get one you can
say [ __ ] one time it looks like
Gollum and a chimpanzee had sex with one
another it is so scary looking anyway so
you what is it why is it different I
don't know it's just so weird it's this
very rounded thing and it looks like a
creature it looks like a different
creature so now that's more stuff about
me it's very introspective about
learning
so okay so all right your ultimate
travel destination where would you want
to go good question
man that's hard I've never been out of
the country except one time on the other
side of the lake right in Baudette
Minnesota and I was in Canada
technically and I peed and then they got
back in the boat yeah
so there's a lot place lately like I'd
want to travel to you I see we're saying
about the face now Dylan I'd like some
men in black oh yeah a really really
secure balance this hurt yeah I don't
blow your lips again do that thing where
you go oh god that is so terrifying so
back to the question I'm curious I I
won't be able to sleep tonight if I
don't know where would you like to go
give it an airline ticket Nick where
would you go
that is so tough um give us the top
three I would have to research this more
is it hurts my ankles more than anything
right I'm okis those mochas are too
thick for the for the brace I will say I
just like one huge trip all over Europe
no you can't do that why the list three
countries Prague it's beautiful what was
that twitch you just me Oh speech is
affected when you're upside down over
long periods of time yeah something
Bad's gonna happen to your brain I think
tactile and yeah that's great time there
yeah I actually have a friend in
Thailand right now just been vicariously
living turn their Instagram stories for
its poison I don't know it's making me
feel it feel like I've experienced it I
feel like I feel like Instagram so
what'd you make and a lot of people
demonize it ooh you know it would be fun
if I did this give me [ __ ] worst beat
me try it out I'm a really cool guy um
okay so speaking of cool Oh favorite
celebrity crush top three girls not like
Jenna
Rhianna rachel mcadams right I'm Cassie
Randolph sister okay nice got it
Michelle Randolph okay agree with the
Rihanna one although what she her eyes
like she's a few chromosomes off and
being you know so we'd have a beautiful
baby then little a little off how much
time yet we are at six minutes and forty
seconds now I'm more bored than anything
right right and as are the audience so
let me do this I will tell you guys and
we need a one shot otherwise they won't
believe it we've had plenty of one shots
but you know many people know that we
worked the Adam Carolla studio one of
our co-workers is named Kaelyn it was a
lovely human being I love him with all
my heart maybe not all of it but he said
one of the dumbest things I've ever
heard in my life the other day you okay
yeah you only have seven more minutes to
go which is the entirety of this so far
so thank you okay okay so Caitlin said I
got a riddle for you
oh wow because two guys walk into a bar
none of them death let's see if you
could your your tongue your tummy looks
incredible I don't think you have
anything to worry about and I'm not
saying that sarcastically yeah so
anyways so Caitlin goes to guys walk
into a bar right and jokes always end so
funny when it starts on that premise I
can well this is a riddle this isn't a
jaw okay so two guys just
[Laughter]
go to sleep I just gotta accept it so
two guys walk into a bar right one guy
orders whiskey meet the other guy orders
whiskey on the rocks
the guy the orders whisky on the rocks
dies what could have killed him it's the
ice clearly it's the ice he just told
the riddle
okay okay oh it was like it has to be
not the ice I want to see the ice every
instinct in my body saying ice I was
like it's clearly the ice because that's
the only difference between the two cups
news like yeah I think I'm gonna kill
that riddle wrong did you ever figure
out the correct way to say in a riddle
the birthday playing say the riddle do
you I am where I'm not gonna hold it
against you if you don't give up yet so
we tap out yeah if your ankles are
seriously hurting and you feel like you
might have I don't know like some type
of major circulation type thing going on
up there then then we can let you down
okay all right I'm gonna get a drink how
much time we got left
we got adjusting is the worst thing it
actually makes it worse we got five more
minutes so yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna get
a drink - I'll keep you guys entertained
eggie eggie [ __ ] Ely wetter than an
Amazon tastes this kitty silly Bailey
poppin pili smoking I kissed your lick
this feeling moldable I so come I look
I'm like fat after shot that's all I can
remember right now nope I've been keto
pretty strictly for the past two days
and Jackyl guys wanna hear me rap some
more
look got notice today my back so and
backup occurs like a bearskin rug put
something on the floor button on the go
little wrapping up some beer weak plug I
could burn I could work in the world and
we're gonna ask my Brotherhood cooker
that search with words from an above
thank you very much that I got what I
got my math where math like a ain't a
circle with pay little hook I'd like to
see you miss EOG from the seat oh damn I
messed it up I heard footsteps I can't
wait to tell Ben Greenville to suck my
fat dude no no here off beat them so you
can you hold the camera and all I'll go
ahead yeah we've been doing it like this
not landscape yeah [ __ ] with someone no
yeah no no up and down you did you up
and down the whole time yeah at first I
wanted now interesting notion
interesting debate no Nick
each is from cheese like a quote adult
right he just eats it like this like the
whole stick but right now whatever we
have oh we're there man oh yeah 11
minutes and 33 now really zoom in a hug
this because this is gonna be a
horrifying really scary that's the power
of your organs I literally big there's
nothing like it
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm just very self-conscious about my
looks yeah Nick is that she's sitting
right at like your nipples boy where is
the cheese right now my tears are just
going back into my eyeball so it's very
weird yeah oh my god that's so funny you
know we can always get more cheese no
there's there's quite a bit left here
especially if we have ration properly
how much time is left
yeah basically a minute and Nick you
only got 1 minute 45 seconds yeah yeah
so you know the monster from The Goonies
yeah yeah that guy really look like that
was across the shut up it was it crunch
something face was it this reminds me of
feeding like that kind of hey you got
reminded of feeding like something like
that I wonder if I'm gonna have to get
my feet in a putative I'm down nothing
sharp when I feel nothing I can get
through a bone steep steak knives yeah
we're kind of petering out guys
no no I think we just gotta basically
all right we got 60 seconds left
whoa final 60 seconds you proved me
wrong
I tweeted a video of dr. Drew doing this
the other day you did like eating cheese
upside down no but it was he was doing
the inversion table and I said do you
think I'm gonna be taller after this I
said the end of maybe I said at the end
of the video you're supposed to do it
for 15 minutes jokingly oh there it is
you have been doing keto look at these
riblets those are nice thanks Lydia
what's up ladies
Oh change is falling out now here trapa
dives
tuck that tuck that right into the the
me NDSU hey guys for time sake we said
we were gonna cut this exactly at 15
minutes right so should we just cut it
at 15 we just want to make it to 15
minutes yeah yeah Nick no no no stop